y en directo a Vamos hasta Perú con
nuestro corresponsal Francisco Zacarías
porque hay dos noticias que tienen que
ver con dos personas que ocuparon el
cargo de Primer Ministro durante la
presidencia del destituido Pedro
Castillo Francisco muy buenas noches
como lo mencionamos al inicio de esta
emisión la ex primera ministra Betsy
Chávez fue detenida por la policía luego
de que la justicia peruana respaldar el
pedido de la Fiscalía de 18 meses de
prisión preventiva en su contra
cuéntenos que sigue ahora
Buenas noches likes primer ministra
Betsy Chávez fue detenida en su vivienda
en la región tacna ubicada al sur de
Perú la orden de la Corte Suprema de
este país es trasladarla a Lima para
luego ser dispuesta en una carceleta del
poder judicial sin embargo la ex primer
ministra peruana ha señalado que va a
solicitar a la justicia a este país ser
encarcelada en una prisión de su región
porque afirma que tiene que sustentar
una tesis y además publicar un libro sin
embargo tras ser revisada por los
médicos legistas y pasar los exámenes
conforme a la legislación peruana
echaves tendrá que ser trasladada a una
prisión de mujeres de chorridos ubicada
al sur de Lima allí tendrá que cumplir
los 18 meses de prisión preventiva por
los presuntos delitos de rebelión y
conspiración por supuestamente haber
participado en el fallido intento del
golpe de estado del ex presidente Pedro
Castillo el 7 de diciembre del año 2022
al respecto minutos de su captura Chávez
dijo que para muchos en diversos
sectores del país quisieran ver la
derrotada y caída Chávez aseguró que eso
no será así y prometió que pronto la
verán volver por su parte Los Defensores
de la Primer Ministro peruana han dicho
que van a agotar la vía penal y después
Solicitar a través del tribunal
constitucional que se revierta la orden
de prisión preventiva Mientras tanto
Francisco el ex Primer Ministro guido
bellido presentará un proyecto de ley
con el que pretende dar amnistía al
expresidente Pedro Castillo que tan
viable es esto
guido bellido ha señalado que el
proyecto de ley la misiva solamente será
por los delitos de rebelión y
conspiración y no por otros delitos por
los que es investigado el expresidente
Pedro Castillo Al respecto algunos
juristas han señalado que este proyecto
de ley es inviable porque la amnistía O
indulto solamente corresponde a personas
que han sido condenadas y manifiestan
que el expresidente Pedro Castillo no ha
recibido sentencia Y en este momento se
encuentra solamente investigado por la
justicia además sostienen que no debe
haber leyes con nombre propio las leyes
deben ser igual para todos los
ciudadanos y no solamente para algunos y
en ese sentido también advierte que si
guido bellido lograse reunir los 66
votos del parlamento para aprobar esta
Norma corre el riesgo que en cualquier
momento un juez declare que esta ley es
inconstitucional y su intento termine
solamente en eso en un intento